we are very excited for our next guest
what do we got Nate Christine baransky a
legend in the house today for more than
a decade this Emmy Tony Award winner has
graced your TV screens as attorney Diane
Lockhart first on the hit CBS series a
good wife and then on it spin-off the
good fight that's on Paramount plus now
she's saying goodbye to this beloved
character in the show's final season
here's a taste let me ask you
is Liz trying to get you to team up
against
team up
well I know she's worried about being
challenged for the top spot
but we're in this together
in what
rebuilding her father's Legacy
what are we laughing about oh no no
we're not laughing I'm laughing
[Music]
I just realized that I just may have the
most power because I don't have any
power
oh she's still got power Christine
baransky joins us in the studio we felt
it the minute you walked in the room
power coming in power coming in so
Christine I don't know if we're ready I
don't know if we're ready to let you go
are you ready no I don't think I am I've
been I've played this character for 13
years yes and it it not only the
character but the people with whom I
work the whole atmosphere it took me
through so many times of my life
marriage and and losing my husband and
getting three grandchildren and and it's
just part of the fabric of of my life
and and the character too you know
articulate intelligent passionate
liberal feminist I I liked Walking In
Her Shoes but there's no show and you
walk in her shoes very well she wears
very nice shoes and very nice dresses
but you know there's no other show like
this on the air on any platform because
you guys tell stories in real time
sometimes shockingly so I know and it
wasn't even intended that way but we
were shooting the pilot for the good
fight
six years ago and it was election night
and Donald Trump became you know was
claimed the winner and suddenly the show
took a pivot and became about what it is
like what it has been like and you use
real names that's the thing sometimes
shows will take no headlines but they
don't use the real names you all you
know we're pretty we're all the people
we're pretty brave and it's and and also
the show is
you know address topics that are that
are utterly prevalent in fact the final
season takes us up practically to
election night which is uncanny our our
season finale Will Will just abut that
election night with all of the anxiety
and and
um you know the the precipitous moment
that that we're we're living through the
show takes us through that so yeah I'm
very proud of the show for that reason
and people will look back and think wow
that captured this crazy dystopian time
in our country but I'm so proud and
happy for you last time you were here
you said I'm working harder than I've
ever been I look better than I've ever
been did I say that you did a little
arrogant no it was no it wasn't arrogant
you didn't say it in an arrogant way you
didn't you didn't well I feel better
yeah you did not say it in an arrogant
way and you said I'm making more money
than I ever have okay all right and now
you're 70 years old and you you claim
that very proudly do you still feel all
of those things I do you know I just
finished the Gilded Age last Thursday
and and so I was number one on on two
call sheets and and doing you know
finishing one show and a day later just
going right into the next show and you
know you know what it's like getting up
4 30 in the morning to you know get in
the van and and spend a 12 14 hour day
and I thought damn I'm still doing this
and I still love having fun and damn
good doing it
yes I I would hope that I'm an
inspiration because I think life can get
better and better especially for women
we raise our children we hold things
together
why do we think suddenly that it's it's
ending just when in fact so many aspects
of your life can open up I agree you
know travel learning I took us several
courses at Oxford and a summer program
I've got grandchildren I've got family
I've Got Friends life is you know
where's the wood life is good it's good
so so what's next for you speaking of uh
going on a little vacation I'm going
well deserved tomorrow I'm going on a
vacation but um Broadway
oh I don't you know I think uh if we're
lucky Gilded Age will come back for a
third season because it's so popular and
it's just a fantastic show and that
would take me into yet another cycle and
of course you know that that's eight to
ten episodes that takes at least six to
nine months okay but no you know that's
life in a course at new wig but you know
people say it has the best dialogue and
that you have the best lines in the show
it's definitely a contract the best
place
otherwise they don't show up that you
get to say what are the roles that you
were dying to play that are out there
that you would like you know I I have
Juilliard training and we we train to do
classical plays and I love language and
I would love honestly to do Shakespeare
or to do a play like Tom stopper that
really demands
you know
the skills that I attained in in drama
school and and honestly the Gilded Age
makes a lot of use of that because of of
the formality of the dialogue and the
and the setting that old New York and
she's such an old New York character so
um yeah I would love to just you know
have
well-written monologues and and just get
to sink my teeth into something language
you know people and I think if there's
anything you want to do your life really
is yours to design they don't call you a
legend for nothing when they come up
with a name for whatever age we're
living through now you can be in that
show it'll be terrific yeah yeah thanks
so much it's such a pleasure thank you
congratulations congrats and your
grandmother name is what Minnie Minnie
Minnie I like it congratulations to you
well sharers Gail well I'm working on it
and the child is how old seven now
it's either going to be Gaia or gangan
whatever yeah we gotta figure this out
I know he's almost in high school
sentences it's gonna be Minnie thank you
Christine thank you the good fight is
now streaming now on Paramount
you don't need God jokes with new
episodes out on Thursdays